this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
I I am my testosterone I want to
apologize if this podcast gets a little
heated and if there's there's I slap
Brandon or something happens because
I was I've been watching swamp Kings and
um man Florida Florida's got some
football everybody
Gators back then especially dude those
guys Urban Meyer was like I'm the best
teams ever I'm gonna break these whoever
can't handle this insane training is
well I don't want you here that but the
thing when I watch that that's pretty
much division one football is it really
yeah high level we did the exact same
thing you did huh called Dirty dozens
just killing each other yeah and they're
just trying to weed out the week
but I think it's good for people to see
it is
um I would imagine also that the bond
that those guys have yes brings
everybody together especially the top
dogs like the people who are actually a
play yeah get really really cool I get a
little sad too sometimes because
sometimes it's like that might be the
highlight of your life at that age like
that might be the the the best time of
the Pinnacle of your life and for most
of us it isn't that right we get older
we have kids we we're still
accomplishing when you're an athlete and
and and the other thing is I looked up a
lot of those guys and what their Pro
careers were some of them had good Pro
careers a lot of them didn't a lot of
them had two years in the NFL which is
nothing you know it's not I'm not spikes
like the main captain on defense at like
a seven year which is good so all right
yeah Tebow you know not a decent career
what a stud though uh Percy Harvin's was
a stud but then he always personally
Harvard he always had some he's had some
issues mental issues oh is that what it
was how long have you planted Pros
person I don't know freak freak Tim Tim
says the best athlete he's ever seen
that's what Evan Meyer said he said he's
the best athlete how about Urban Meyer
on that he goes we won the National
Championship everyone's in the locker
room celebrating I go to my office to
start recruiting kids he's like it was
never enough it never ends they start
taking Ambience and got addicted to that
drinking I don't tell me I haven't
gotten that part yet
yeah anyone knows football because
because then he and then he retired
because he had like a heart issue
because he was just the stress he was
putting himself on it I didn't know that
and he was never happy he was never
happy yeah he retired
then he went to Ohio State won the
National Championship with Ohio State I
spoke to team that yeah that's why they
won I think right that's how we know him
yep and then uh after that then he went
to Jacksonville they went to the NFL and
it was a horrible mistake it was because
he tried implementing that same strict
with the pros those kids yeah they're
not kids there those are grown men who
are like do what [__] yeah but we've
only been through that we've obviously
made it and so just it was a complete
failure I love every mother he's the
best he is and um uh the Tim Tebow when
I think don't people don't realize like
me people like me who don't watch uh
college football
I don't think they realize the level of
Fame a guy like Tim Tebow has in this
country so you don't mean Tim are close
all right especially that's how I know
you're super close yeah you know he was
the number one selling jersey in the
world over Michael Jordan LeBron James
when he was playing college football
World International because think about
like he's had such a big he was
Christian following beautiful yeah is
anybody better looking I mean be tough
right yeah and and and here's the thing
about him right now right now with Tim
he's
6'4 and his legs and his he's so jacked
in this thing I don't know what he's
doing just lifting weights all the time
but he's gotten more jacked and his legs
are what what what will blow your
[__] mind such a good guy he's such a
hard worker but also he's also regarded
as top three best college football
players of all time top three that team
is regarded as I mean top definitely top
so I haven't gotten yet to the point
where he's starting in this document so
you're like one episode in I'm two
episodes in so right now they just when
there's they're at the one yard line
they just give it to me and then people
start they put in Chris Leake who's the
starter and they boo him yeah and so
they're just the demand demand for Tim
because he was the number my question to
you is this how much is that is racism
how much is that is oh not racist no no
Tim's it's just that's so stupid that
narrative they try to spin yeah but it's
in the South and it's Florida no oh was
it the right choice he's the best
college football player of all time is
it racism Brian yeah is it racism yeah
is it well he was young oh why because
he was 18. oh why because they went to
two next championships one one could
have went to three is it racism you
stupid [__] you woke cuck hey hey don't
call me that do we think it's racism
that they put Tim TV this is sports
Urban Meyer doesn't give a [__] if the
team was all Korean you know I
understand but they're winning games but
they wouldn't they don't care if it was
all right call me what did you call me
Hillary supporter whatever yeah dude I'm
just asking one question you can't
[__] cast me as a woke up Hillary
just just go back
yeah was it racist that Tim would you
put in the game I just thought maybe
he's beautiful but he's beautiful and
he's the number one recruit in the
nation Brian well but he was also 18. I
just figured that you got the he's just
a better player all right and and
obviously history to put him in there at
first because he wasn't he's a freshman
he wasn't ready but then when they put a
mini performed they're like okay he's
ready that's how it goes in college
football yeah Jesus and they won a
national championship bro take it easy
they wouldn't want to ask Championship
with League yeah they do it with Timmy
yeah you didn't play quarterback because
your hands weren't big enough right no
my Palms are big so I can grab a
football you know I grew up basketball I
don't know if you can okay you have
small fingers though not to be a dick no
you don't no you don't have good fingers
for basketball or for throwing football
that's true no I can pull I can Palm a
ball because I have big Palms yeah but
you have short fingers I don't know if
they're shorts it's almost a defect no
not to be a dick but compared to you on
Brock Lesnar no it's not true because
look your fingers are it's look at that
look at how short this is why you're
doing look hey take it go pull the Palm
I'm going to do you mind I'm going I'm
showing you how long my fingers are my
fingers are as long as you're trying to
you keep going up but look look no do
this do this don't here do this
you don't have Me by that much Bubba and
hey can you let go of me I can rip over
yourself you can't come here no I'm
sorry that's what it is
no I don't need to dude my fingers are
as long as yours and that's it that's
not even close you know if that's the
truth you wish you wish if anything on
your body it's like mine get it yeah get
up get a [__] measuring tape right
now damn it you had one before right get
a measuring tape and this is a problem
do it your appendages are short and
that's fine my legs are not short my
legs are long legs you have long legs
you have long legs pretty long arms
short fingers what I'm trying to say is
that you you you're not a you're not a
thrower is that fair uh no when we did
the throne in college this is why the
common folk doesn't care
oh yeah yeah you did yeah yeah we well
we all did yeah so they do the longest
throw I finished second
if in a second in a second bud in
throwing yes Joe clatt beat me are you
making this up right now no no we used
to always do it because I've thrown the
old pig skin around with you and I'm you
know some football with me yeah we did
we've never thought that Jeff's place
yeah who's Tempest we were throwing the
old pig skin around no and we just never
chucked the pixels on the beach too now
we chucked and you saw it and you you
were like I remember you said this you
go dude your hands are pretty crazy for
a guy who doesn't play D1 football and I
said Thank you and then you said and
then you said and you got some crazy
speed and you're and your girl at the
time who became your wife said he's
surprisingly explosive and you said and
you said you have no idea and then she
said wow and then you said the rumor is
he's got a crazy piece as well and she
said Brian and you said you have no idea
so first then I said thank you for that
compliment right thank you for that
compliment and then hey when you watch
the football stuff you go I'm [__] 100
a little bit right no not not a little
bit yeah I I I I there's such that
division one level there's such freaks
physically first of all they're so big
and strong especially at Florida but in
general that that's how it is man
monsters they're monsters like Tim like
like uh some of those dudes bouncy
Brothers yeah spikes I 100 feel like a
[__] because well I am see the truth is
think of my college experience compared
[Laughter]
don't laugh about that no hold on let me
just say something you're a college okay
okay
dude I'll just all right you're a big
that work ethic never leaves you
all right dude I know but I'm just
that's why you're kind of Spacey all
over let's do the podcast Tuesday let's
do it Thursday what does this matter how
do I run social media oh that is not me
dude you see me just a grind no you're
being disrespectful about it
I couldn't be like Daddy can you bail me
out no there's nothing I didn't do that
Daddy call my dad I call this secretary
yeah there's a difference big difference
uh no it's it is true though as a
regular guy when you see those dudes and
you go
well no here's what here's all
seriousness do you go if you say you're
an athlete you might say you can run
fast and you can throw in your
coordinated you ain't an athlete till
you've had the mental fortitude to
suffer for that long through that kind
of what's the difference in the UFC like
from the top five to the Champs like the
Champions willing to suffer the skill
set wise everyone can kick punch grapple
for the most part but the skill set wise
of the the mental fortitude to get
through like you're down two rounds on
the card and does not affect them they
just power through it that's the
difference said that in college he never
took a day off like he was so obsessed
with wrestling and that's one of the
reasons he was so amazing people like
that are able to suffer longer than most
other people Timmy never too I never Tim
never took it down you're only traveling
together you get off the building
Tim is one of those guys that if he had
been in the UFC or anything I think he
would have been an absolute monster and
anything oh you think yeah a Monster
yeah no [__] there's nobody trained like
him no and nobody was as Fierce a
competitor and again
we do a little measurement it's all good
sure George come on over here you can
measure us
okay get in there Georgie so we'll do it
from I don't trust you from wrist to
Palm no we'll do our fingers Bubba well
no no no no we're doing the whole entire
hand okay we can do that that's what I'm
saying do the hand first we don't want
the project to come in a screeching halt
so let's just do it fast but let's do
the fingers I know so just go to
whatever the 10 it is
but George I need you to because he
cheats from the rest to there
eight on the dot it looks like eight on
the DOT
George what am I I'm right there
about
a few centimeters under eight
yeah so I got the same size hands no
penises I'm bigger Bubba you got me by a
couple centimeters is that big or no
it's a tiny bit bigger bigger though I
want you to be and I don't need you to
be such a stickler for detail I know I
know talk about a bit bigger oh it's a
shame though what think what these hands
have done compared to yours Hey Hey
listen no but you're 41 football I get
it and find the UFC not big all right
and then I hold Mike's now so do you so
here's the thing though
think what these hands have done and you
have the same size hands that's the
that's the comparison here you're making
me mad nothing oh [__] I've done nothing
I was [__] I've I've continued to do
Sports
it's a bummer right and I'll tell you
something else I'm not even asking for
this if I had been born with that bone
structure I would have been
on that team you'd be right here buddy
write that on that without those
experiences
University of Florida I got a strong
[__]
mind let's go one more let's go one more
yeah everyone everyone gives it to
wrestlers it's it's tough surprising
it's very similar those hot guys go
through the same [__] but all the
original one programs it's such a
Nightmare Man such a nightmare it's so
good I do think there's a difference in
football and everything else
and even you know I think that you play
with pain
but I think you play with more pain with
football I just think the compared to
what almost any other sport the
concussions the mma's tough dude hockey
stuff yeah yeah that's true listen let's
take a little break can we take a break
yes I do life happens dude you're
talking about injuries you can get
injured you can get injured in a car
accident 35 percent fatal accidents
occur between 6 p.m and midnight did you
know that oh it's not no freaking clue
and if you're ever injured you can check
out Morgan and Morgan man Morgan Morgan
Law Firm yep they have over a hundred
offices Nationwide more than 800
freaking lawyers with over 15 billion
recovered for over 300 000 clients
Morgan Morgan has proven track record of
fighting get you your full and Fair
competition I know but is it hard isn't
it hard to go through all the you gotta
file a claim dude it's so freaking easy
dude it's so freaking easy it's too you
know it's too easy to make a claim yeah
it's a simple click here button here
it's like download an app it's so
freaking it's like just eight clicks
maybe on your phone you can do it from
your couch really quickly just sitting
there in your jammies have you ever
injured you can check out Morgan Morgan
their fee is free unless you win so
their fee is free I can just follow it
they only make money if you make money
for more information go to
forthepeople.com fighter or dial pound
law that's pound529 from your cell phone
that's for the people.com
fighter all right or pound law pound 529
from your cell this is a paid
advertisement Morgan
listen macadamia nuts are the most
healthy nuts are the most delicious how
many it's not just for the rich anymore
I cooked my steak with their extra
virgin macadamia nut oil talk about
buttery flavor and high smoke point
listen dude I gobble those chocolate
covered yeah yeah they are addictive
they're they're buttery that's the main
thing I can say smooth if you're if you
want the best nuts on planet it's only
nuts that touch these lips they also are
really good at satiating your hunger so
you don't have to take in a lot of
calories but tell me about the bars all
right the bars are made of 45 of the
bars are are pure macadamia nuts okay
it's not a whole bunch of filler and
stuff like that they've got all
different kinds of flavors at the end of
the day it is the best tasting nut on
the planet dude and they never do
discounts but I said House of macadamus
we got to do something here they said
okay buddy how about this for a very
special offer for all the friends of
fire and the kid for a limit time
they're giving me a free box of 20 35
Macadamia snack bars one of each flavor
you love it cool order your own box
whichever flavor you love go to House of
macadamias.com tfak you get 20 off your
entire order with the code tfak the best
tasting nuts ever ever but I think
football though there's a reason for
like baseball you don't think it's tough
you want to talk about athletes pitchers
100 those pictures are for us
freaks any high level I'm saying more I
get into baseball and I see these
pictures like those guys are still 100
pitches Giants and how fast they throw
it over and over and your body's not
meant to do that talking about 100 miles
per hour and throwing junk and
curveballs and there is a difference
though between baseball and football
football you are playing with some kind
of an injury always but so so like easy
easy next week you're never 100 that's
true
that's the nature of the game but again
that's that's that's you're getting hit
you're [__] you know so UFC you know
what I did you know what I don't like on
that documentary this is a spoiler alert
but they don't cover any of the darkness
they don't and there was darkness no
that's I mean the darkest team of all
time to be successful arrests and crazy
[__] I mean murders arrest what yeah
yeah
yeah a guy got murdered and they thought
it was in Hernandez like first murder
when he's on the team I forgot that
Aaron Hernandez was on that team yeah I
didn't see they barely talk about it
they show a picture of them and then
that's it they barely show him he was a
big part of that team man they show him
catch a touchdown pass forget maybe
against Texas something like that or USC
but so this is this is not at this is
they don't cover in the dock Ohio State
or you're saying that Swan the swamp
Kings uh swamp King yeah they don't
cover any of the that's my one criticism
of that documentary they covered like
that's this part of the story
yeah yeah it's insane it'd be like
having a documentary on OJ Simpson just
go bypassing the murder oh this happened
and then just keep going whoa that's a
big deal right although the the ball
though I would say that the Aaron
Hernandez stuff happened after no it
didn't no no it didn't no I mean the
when he got recruit when he got drafted
to the New England Patriots in those
murders but there were stuff going on in
University of Florida the pounces and
all that like this and didn't he have
was it there that he was having sex with
someone on the team a guy yeah I don't
know they didn't get and then Cam Newton
was also on that team he got kicked off
Cam Newton was on that team [__] what he
was a backup to Tim Cam Newton was the
backup I didn't know that and then he
got kicked out of University of Florida
for stealing a laptop what
they don't talk about any of this damn
dude yeah Cam Newton was on that team
the team was filthy filthy that that's a
decision when you're editing it that's
the decision you make where you go what
are we going to focus on you know
because but then they talk about at the
end they talk about Urban Myers downfall
like but what about the kids like that
was one of the main problems with this
team they're so damn good and successful
that you had all you had these amazing
athletes there's so many dark arts going
on yeah that Urban and like that one
alignment talks about he goes people
think like the politicians run Florida
or you know the governor the football
team and and they don't talk about how
Urban Meyer got swept a lot of stuff
under the rug you're talking about
horrible [__] just keep the kids
available keep them active that's the
other thing that I didn't know because
I'm see I didn't grow up in this country
so I mean sounds naive but I'm being
really serious like when I saw that
documentary and you are a 19 and 20 21
year old and I texted you about this and
you have a hundred and ten thousand
people screaming and that when you walk
in anywhere anywhere in that town and
you're like 19 year old kid from like
this very small like a a bad
neighborhood the hood or whatever and
all of a sudden people are cheering you
on or booing you or whatever it might be
it's life and death well Tim can go to
class he gets so famous he can go to
class he had to take it online that's so
nuts because they would literally shut
down the class what because kids would
find out where he's at and bombard their
classroom Jesus he's signed an
autographs celebrity
that's what happened to that the girl
who's the baller for LSU she's the
pretty girl oh she can't go to class
anymore the girl from LSU the number one
nil girl who's making all the money she
can't go to class anymore who's that
who's a gymnast yeah Olivia yeah yeah
she can't go to class anymore she's too
famous wow so those kids they lose out
on them well at least those kids are
making millions think about how much Tim
Tebow would have made off his jersey
what's cool about her so she so she's
obviously a freak athlete and complete
Dime Piece her boyfriend was the number
one pick from LSU he's the pitcher he's
the number one pick in the MLB signed a
9 million dollar deal I think wow that's
her man makes sense nine million dollar
deal in college no he got drafted high
school kids making money now look at how
gorgeous she is Jesus yeah
good God
yeah she's cool very talented
there you go
um but like the the kid Peyton Manning's
nephew who who's the backup at Texas is
making more at Texas Archie's making
more at Texas being the backup from the
nil deal than most quarterbacks in the
NFL why because he I mean he's like the
next thing is he is he that is oh he's a
freak he's a freak yeah he's a freak
it's like being a Kennedy yeah he's a
Manning think about it Archie Manning
Peyton Manning
Peyton Peyton man I got it didn't Eli
Manning I think his brother was a D1
yeah he was a stud too he got injured
unbelievable
your grandpa's Archie Manning I mean
it's just royalty you're basically
Kennedy or yeah royalty in England you
really are look at that
and then go to him chin he's a stud
um
It's gotta be the same guy now
so there's Archie and there's archman
Archie Manning Jr probably
let's go you're talking about a kid yeah
yeah
well he looks like a Manning I'll tell
you that much
and he's he's uh he's just that good huh
butcher has declined all in uh deals
what is an nil deal the three get paid
name your likeness oh that's right oh
type in uh how much money he's making
maybe it's what he got offered but it's
not unreal
it's cool this I'm on the fence about
these kids getting paid It's just tough
3.7 million is a backup that's nice he's
edging out the likes of Caleb Williams
who's the Heisman Trophy winner for USC
starting quarterback number one drafted
Prospect
he's earning 1.1 million more than USC's
Heisman Trophy winning quarterback so
far he hasn't played it down
um good for him though like these kids
it's good and bad right it's good and
the problem is
the Dynamics of the team he's a backup
quarterback and he's making three
million dollars a year right you have
kids on that team like it just it
separates the team so he pulls up in a
Bentley and these kids are 17 18. and
he's a backup he's not playing the Stars
like hopefully he's gonna be resentment
there hopefully his brother his his
uncles and his grandfather and his
father can is that whose father is
Archie Mannings I think he's the one
that didn't make it so at least he's
which is why he's hosting he's got those
that whole group of people yeah but
that's one kid think about the rest of
the college football yeah so if I'm a
lineman lineman don't make money but I'm
the star I'm the All-American protecting
this quarterback who's decent but he's
making more money than me it's gonna be
the Dynamics are just weird and the
resentment
though it's like kind of like actors and
comics and some people do really oh yeah
because they're so good at money yeah
but I'm saying 18 year old managing
three million dollars it's a disaster
disaster the pros don't manage it well
that's why there's the 30 for 30 broke
and they don't cover mortgages taxes
health insurance all that they don't
cover any of that stuff then you get out
you're like all right I guess this guy
says he can do it I'm gonna give it to
give him all my money to him and then he
screws you over because you're not
you're 21 with 10 million dollars in the
bank
and you buy a 10 million dollar house
and that's a good idea man you'll be all
pro okay so 10 million dollar house I
have to put down 20 percent
and then you play for three years you
got this huge nut no one teaches you
that stuff crazy yes I thought I heard
that they do now in the NFL I heard they
teach you like you have one [__]
class that's it yeah
the UFC does it you'll see Summit hey
everybody okay here be smart with your
money
that's our time is that it yeah but
again it's not it's not on them is it
one of the things they said that the
reason a lot of people go broke is
friends and family so you you you what's
the number one way but they alert that
to you in the NFL the number one thing
though as soon as it's announced when
you get drafted whatever the number one
reason people go broke is friends and
family mainly family so everyone's gonna
be reaching for money everyone's gonna
be asking for money so they do warn you
on that but what are you gonna do you
want to do this you and I be broke as
[__] damn me I'm working on now you're
this 21 year old kid and your mom who
raised you is like hey honey I need this
five million dollar house you're like
well my signing bonus was six million so
yeah it makes sense hey Bubba unless you
pay for that how house cash just
outright cash those payments that's a
20-year mortgage 30-year mortgage yeah
taxes if in Florida in Texas where's
this house at they don't think about
this stuff even a million times
foreign
guys I've not been very good with my
money everybody anybody
that's right I make what I spend what I
make you know what I'm saying
I'm not the guy to teach you Financial
Fitness and I should know better but I
don't I have the same spending that
Kodak Black does it's not good that's
right that's trying to know who that is
because he's old as [__] right I do
because I know you can get that I know
his lawyer very well
yeah Kodak Black went to jail for the
for three years for the same crime that
Hunter Biden committed and uh but
Hunter's gonna be in a world of [__] now
because when it's starting to come out
well now nobody's protected well the
judge in Delaware was like hold on just
tune your dicey formula I'd stick by it
oh [__] Dion Sanders brought in Brittany
Renner to teach his player how to avoid
hoes that's brilliant who is Brittany
Renner
hey come on man I'm an old guy oh my god
dude yeah I know dumbass no I'm not [__]
you dude
Renner is uh notoriously known for going
after athletes and famous people really
she liked the way she's a dime piece oh
so she's a dime bad guy well who
wouldn't go after athletes I don't blame
these girls rich and handsome as [__]
yeah calm down but so so Dion's
brilliant he brought her in because
she's a pro she's like these are the Red
Flags this is what they're gonna come
for this what they look like this what
how they talk so it's brilliant by Dion
I love Dion and I love magic mine heard
Dion used I heard Dion use his magic
mine you know a lot of his foot fell off
a lot of people are using magic mine a
lot uh Magic mind is growing faster
right now at this stage of their their
development than Red Bull or Celsius was
and that's because it works and that's
my commercial for magic mine and that's
why I take it it's a nootropic those
others are just straight energy drinks
you know that's why it's a big
difference yeah it's healthy yep better
for you than coffee all that stuff it's
beautiful and delicious hey can we hear
her talk yeah please clip she's like hey
when I'm sucking dick
she looks hot yeah are you guys not
familiar with her of course I'm not
familiar with it
oh my God
the garlic these are college kids
wait stop for a second who is she they
must they all know her everybody knows
her look at him but who is she yeah
she's just uh she's just a gorgeous girl
who goes for athletes
so my name is Brittany Renner AKA bundle
of Brittany on Instagram I have been on
social media
the world is your oyster you can do
whatever you want and for me my whole
journey on here I felt like my life
almost felt like I was in Disney World
like I like the motivational music yeah
but I think this might be this might be
one of the most important things these
guys could ever hear everybody
so it's like even if we both have our
own thing
me still be
still but you boost my you know what I'm
saying like I boost your stock it's just
that simple you know I'm gonna play this
for my seven-year-old when I get home
this is how to get
a game you think Dion knows a thing or
two about the game of hoes
I had an in-depth conversation with him
and Michael Irvin about that yeah
I I know I I they they ran it as hard as
it gets we all know in a day yeah
yeah well a lot of people don't but you
do everybody does yeah people who know
football and anyone with a heartbeat no
I don't those two I don't yeah but I
don't think even my dad was like Dion
[__] I don't think most people who
don't follow Sports actually understand
and even guys understand like what those
guys actually deal with and the access
they have on on a level you do because
you you know you were in the game but
a lot of people like I I think the
Temptation when you're a superstar like
that is
I I've never seen anything like it
actually I've never seen anything like
that you can see why Dion's getting all
these recruits the most recruits the
biggest recruiting class from going when
in one game to Dion signing now they
have all these transfers like the
biggest recruitment class they have all
five stars now across the board this is
one of the reasons like is is the coach
of Auburn bringing Brittany Renner no
it's amazing no no I'm gonna have my
seven-year-old and three-year-old watch
as well you should sir say hey here's
what's going on the seven-year-old is
going to be a s-t-u-d he's already
there's a real stud on his baseball team
he's got he's got he's got some
athleticism though some strength boss is
the outlier because he has attitude too
and he sees his brother
so he's just sit and study and then
we'll be like do it and he can do a bed
and tiger already he can do more
push-ups than tiger already what
what drives tiger nuts oh no that's I'm
like I'm telling you bud you might be
the best thing in the world though
because it creates this crazy
competitive Spirit yeah that's what me
and my brother yeah you guys yeah really
oh yeah yeah oh yeah most people that
make the NFL will have older brothers
yeah it's a common denominator most of
them have that older rivalry I think
Fighters too I think I think a lot of
Fighters had an older look at Jon Jones
you know
Chris Weidman he talks about that you
know
interesting
interesting for those kids yeah
especially now the nil deal like they're
gonna have money can you imagine I can't
imagine if I was 21 like when I was 30 I
started making real money at 20. no I
couldn't handle it
wait we've been doing this putt yeah
when I was 30 I started making legit
money
that's right legit money when I was 30.
10 years ago we've been doing podcast
two years we started doing fire kid live
started seeing checks I remember you
sent me a picture of the check we made
and I went the [__] yeah let's go [__]
we're making actual books remember I was
like stand up and acting in that way you
know and then you were like how about
this I think you said something like uh
we can get used to this I went damn yeah
10 years ago a third even then I took me
probably
I mean even now I don't really have a
grasp on it you know I have properties
and stuff like that but I don't have a
grasp on it
and I'm surrounded by some [__]
they're good with money man yeah now
think of these young kids three million
dollars and you're 20 or no matter you
better have a good you better have
somebody who really understands or you
better have fun bro no no did you have
fun
no you're a bad you're a bad business
how about today is Tiger's first day of
second grade we're driving and his mom's
like is your friend this we're gonna be
over there I'm like okay you're gonna
stick up for your [__] self this year
somebody bullish you you punch them
right in the [__] and Joanna was like
hey hey what are you doing I was like
I'm sorry I just you would love she is
way too intense I'm like I'm so sorry
you would love my son you love my son
goes to school
he's got a pair of fake glasses on a
fedora and it carries a briefcase
he's a detective he's like you though he
loves fashion yeah
you like why were those scarf
in the summertime like they had I wore
Monday people were like oh that's the
thing to wear like I've been doing that
since I was a kid man we're outlandish
so it's the same way he shows up I don't
know what it is I wonder what that is I
wonder what that is he loves shoes he's
like I just want shoes he wants the
Jordans he knows all about it I I got
from suplex I got him two pairs of shoes
and he was like he knew exactly what
they were yeah
and I was like damn
so you saw that I gave uh the suplex uh
Mike gave me those uh Jordans that were
chocolate the chocolate uh the mocha
Locas I didn't know what they were
they're 700 they just released I had no
idea to re-released them they're saying
I gave them to my nephew because because
they were a little big on me and my
nephew loved them and then he grew out
of them but like he told me like he
couldn't believe it and my son saw them
he was like those are the mocha George
he wants them yeah your son needs to
talk to me yeah yeah because you know
your [__] yeah he's he's all about it
he's all about it uh what do you got
chin
okay
one second look at that old school t5k
shirt dude
you gotta pee I'm coming with you
what do you got chan I like the shirt
chin thank you guys made it look at that
it's actually an amazing shirt there's
teeth I don't I think my girl gave away
all those old school shirts I have like
to find the kids I still have the
jackets I still needed the red jacket
from you I know I gotta find a large in
that for you
great sure but uh yeah so there's Theo
Chris Bobby
Brendan and then bronzer yeah yeah great
just Robin yeah just green Gay Robin it
was so this is a great show though thank
you thank you okay dude it's amazing
yeah
all right so this happened recently this
is a uh this is Del Amo which is like in
Torrance here in California it's not too
far from here
um there's for some reason a bunch of
teenagers just going crazy and brawling
why I'll show you a little bit of it so
there's no real reason at school or what
no no the only thing that could find was
like there was like a discount on the
movie theater it's okay so if you're
like a student or something it was the
discount they do this in New York too
but there's like time people the
witnesses said there was like 400
something people and they would beat
other people up and the reason why I
bring this up is because Henry Gracie
posted this
on his Instagram and this one guy saw
this one dude get chased by a bunch of
people getting beat up and then he just
came in I'll show you this video real
quick this kid in the black and white
hoodie running away from the crowd gets
grabbed from behind pulled to the ground
gets stunned he's just an innocent kid
we don't know the story 10 different
kids are stepping on him look at this
guy and the blue shirt storms in from
out of nowhere puts himself right in the
middle pushes kids off and starts
yelling and separating with every cell
in his body good for that guy yeah into
it the crazy part is I don't know who
the victim was I don't know who's at
fault I don't know why they're fighting
one kid was getting jumped and this guy
black on Asian crime rushes in there and
risks I mean his own life everything you
put out of the most layer I think it's a
race thing you caught he's Cut From a
Different Cloth and the best part is
anybody can get it Torrance California
this happened at Del mama so either way
but the you know so there's mostly black
kids but then there's a black guy that
defended that well I guess
the kid could have been Mexican either
way the the dude that came in to fight
back all those I saw one of the black
kids go get that Asian butt
so we don't know much about this story
but apparently this is the guy what's
wrong with kids though in New York City
if my friend's like okay let's go to the
mall and just fight anybody what I saw
it in New York all the time no no no no
what are you talking about approach the
kids Wild and out they call it but this
guy is apparently his name is that on on
Instagram that boy Reckless and then
he's just all his posts are super like
positive yeah super positive they're
really great yeah he seems just like a
good dude role model look you can you
will oh I like this guy dude and he's
the one that did apparently he's the one
that did it and look I love this one
especially that's a good man gets that
slow money but I say it's the sh it's
faux show Honey the janitor the CEO of
the company we all humans trying to get
by and deserve the same respect people
should get them on the pod
bad guys it's still kind of like a
little bit be funny if it was
we don't know for a fact so but it seems
like that funny comes Isaac yeah I
wasn't there but the thing is
and Dana White reposted uh Henner's
story too I love him so yeah header one
of my favorite people on the planet yep
there's nobody better at talking or
selling them
that's dope I don't I don't get those
kids I don't get it man I don't know
what happened exactly
and 400
who was 400 friends who were down to
jump it's just what happens is they get
out of school and there's always already
beef and school going on that's that mob
mentality the minute they get off campus
so I need Sports they break yeah that's
why my kids don't have 100 when they get
to high school it could get a little
dicey if there's a discussion there but
right now they don't have they have to
do Sports it keeps them out of trouble
keeps them disciplined keeps them having
a goal there's no choice if you live in
my house them the rules I mean they're
in my house you gotta play sport every
society always knows that you're
especially boys from the age of like
[__] 13 18 you got to keep them you
don't just let them idle around in
groups no if they get bored that's so
much trouble man there's drugs babies
killings
all that sucking each other off hey man
no that's fine I'm talking about the
violence man I don't know what you're
talking about dude what peanut butter in
your butt hole oh God where's my dog
where's my dog oh there's no dogs just
my friend
but what about CT I'm like hey man I
don't have a splash of CT I've done
pretty well then jump people at the mall
because they're bored yeah
that's right you wouldn't know nothing
about that though [__] why are you
saying that about me I came up hard dude
what do you got Jen
uh so this was something happened in
Saudi Arabia Iggy Azalea was doing a
performing in a concert she's cool and
her pants accidentally ripped but you
can't show especially if you're a female
in Saudi Arabia you can't show skin oh
did they kill her
they didn't kill her no I'll show you
the actual Izzy's Iggy's pants ripped
and they cut her head off no they didn't
kill her but watch see it accidentally
rips here
[Applause]
but that alone that little rip made the
authorities cancel her entire yeah you
shouldn't get stoned
so too bad it didn't cut in the back
just the [__] thigh right there look
at how it just I mean if I bent down
it's kind of a cool look actually she's
like she has like really thick thighs so
yeah yeah she's cool okay she's cool
yeah um so she did say that she said
don't blame the promoters it was the
authorities and then she also said one
other thing
damn they didn't let her finish she goes
I did it I did but I also said ladies
Make some noise it's a woman's world and
apparently that's what made them want to
kiss when she said Saudi Arabia went
excuse me yeah so when she says it was
the police it was the religious police
okay and the mullahs and um the the MS
MBS Mohammed bin Sultan who you might as
well speak in Saudi Arabia he's
modernizing Saudi Arabia but there's
this dance he's doing and there's
there's a quadrant of Saudi Arabia where
you're allowed to do whatever you want
then there's a quadrant where you're you
know well the where she in fact it was
like it's a women's world
she thinks that's what actually pushed
over the edge
yeah they're probably like uh her her
dress ripped like yeah like do we cut
her head off no no but then she yelled
if it's a women's world to it let's
start when I lived there you women
weren't allowed to drive and they
weren't allowed to work so it's changed
now but it's very way less accidents
probably a better world right Brandon
Brendan all right what do you got chance
all right I saw this this is a video I
see from this I think the same account
like multiple times santa.china it's
like kids
sparring with other kids or their
parents so here we go this looks kids
even though that kid looks like an older
dude how old is he's probably 30. oh
that body shot yeah she looks really
good it has to be at least nine or ten
he's got some speed on him oh bad kicks
he's like he's like he's skillful
technique Dad can take a beating too
he's about to knock out dad
Chicago kid this kid is just loving this
[__] look at that body shot oh damn
that's a little much though not elephant
in the room I stopped feeling so much
rice right
for people for being that active yeah
that's true he's growing though he's got
some speed I'm impressed with the kid's
speed he's got he seems to have some
really good technique and good speed
and my parents fed me a ton when I was
growing up I was so fat but then I
started developing getting taller and
bigger so there is 300 pounds yeah there
is a large but I got a bigger hydrate
and I lost potion there I think that kid
or that maybe he's just like you know
baby fat on a certain points
at 10 though with that that's the
parents feeding him yeah like that's on
the parents yeah like when I see a fat
kid I like your parents like what are
you doing dude right at least give him a
chance
all right so these are just a bunch of
silly memes that Georgia memes that I
think are funny never gets old call for
the ball hello ball here we go
hands up
I said call for the ball
for the ball
oh he's cute yeah so he just says hello
ball because he's going like this I call
for the ball mom's like no not like that
dude
and this one's crazy this is a super dad
at a baseball game right here
drops the baby oh Jesus baby okay it'll
replay again you'll see that's
impressive that's enough he's only kid
with one arm you'll see what happens
here after it plays again oh see it
he let go of the kid oh again
catch that's impressive that's
impressive God give him the season
tickets at least are you kidding some oh
You Gotta Give It Up
that kid's like I didn't want the ball
dude and he saves his beard too I like
when they showed that when the that the
MLB games they hit the Home Run and the
kid catches it and Dad's like yeah the
kid throws it back
oh my God
all right here's this one's
this one's a little less this one ends
on a little less positive a note but
teach your kids well
oh
oh yeah
oh cutie pie oh god well that's part of
life ain't it getting a couple Nicks and
bruises who's this guy this is a kid who
besides being the Devil he's coming out
to his little brother oh all right throw
back to when I came out to my brother
his bro's a little young I agree
bro you can't be homophobic
means you don't like gay people
so you're gay
that makes more sense
yeah that makes more sense yeah
I want to play with GI Joe's you kept
want to play with Barbie the fact he
said that that makes more sense
here's another one yeah uh this is what
not to do as a little league catcher
right here
what's he doing what happened he's
probably going to throw the bat the
runner out and just got too excited
again
maybe it's just used to practice maybe
why'd he grab his back like that
hit the back it is back or his or her
back you'll see right here watch
uh I don't see the battery watch
the old kidney
yeah what happened when he was Swang I
wonder what they do with that though
what's the penalty there because the
catcher's in the wrong yeah yeah I I
think it's just uh I think it's death I
think the penal status yeah
um oh this is a crazy little story right
here what is it
fell from the sky and landed on her
you're buying drops the snake as it flew
over so the snake just look at this
if you started attacking her then the
hawk my goodness came back to get its
meal and it also started attacking her
Peggy says the entire ordeal is giving
her a new appreciation for the small
things in the blanket of an eye and the
snap of a finger oh she killed me and
you don't know if a hawk was hunting
our car Wrecker with a snake attack
everybody came back eat a piece of
chocolate it tastes so much better
that's just bad luck that's just called
bad luck this is bad luck or your
neighbor does Voodoo or the hawk senses
you're weak and not that healthy and it
wants to kill and a snake hickey Jones
you know what I'm saying like I wonder
what the chance of that happening
somebody yeah yeah better to win the
lottery I mean wait so the the hawk drop
came back down to get it dropped it on
her yeah on her arm that's a rattlesnake
that's a rattlesnake so she gets tore by
the snake and the Hawk's like that's
lunch [__] comes down and starts
attacking hers I heard a story and it's
probably not true but I love it
when they drop water on Fires they have
these giant scoop things that scoop it
up yeah on the lake and upon and they
they got a guy who was scuba diving or a
snorkeling
and dropped him into trees he was caught
in a tree
that's fake right it's got to be fake
how do you because I'm sure they scan
unless he's down there for a hot second
yeah I don't know you ever see how much
water they drop it's so it doesn't look
like much it's so much water have you
ever seen people under the plane and
they get doused by the water it's crazy
so much water oh yeah
I feel like this and scuba diving tree I
feel like that story is fake though no
so this is Snopes so this is a way of
covering one way to find out is Snopes
legit no there's some like yeah false
[__] oh well I feel like it's happened
before right yeah
it's not true
that's possible though it's possible
dude we watch season one I don't think
you did B maybe Georgie you did but um
oh what the [__]
um not love is blind the ultimatum
have you seen it so ultimately it's
couples that have been together for like
two to seven years and they and one of
the the either the woman or the man go
we you we need to get married move on so
they they put them on the show it's
Nicholas Shea and his girl who host it
Vanessa Manila yeah and so they have the
opportunity to either get married or
break up but before they decide they go
on the show there's whatever six other
couples and they can mix and match and
date for two weeks they live together
would be like to be with a couple and
then you can decide if they want to go
with that partner or get married I've
seen it the season the season finale is
I think tomorrow night but I mean it's
just it's intense it's intense those
people are faced with the truth of like
they're like but the the best is the
couples that they're forced to live here
and they don't get along and when
there's beef that's the best I love it
it's a good show actually it's so good
I've watched it with my my wife loves
that Nick Lachey has they have the
easiest job they show up three times
make so much money it's unbelievable
he's a good guy I I got to know him a
little bit because his wife at the time
her girlfriend at the time was on my
show uh on uh uh what's her name Vanessa
Manilow
um
oh Jessica Simpson yeah
it's a good job
not better than Down With Love but
whatever
what else you got
I think that's pretty much it
we did it again Brent I think we did it
again did it again oops
Wise Guys this weekend September one and
two I'll see Salt Lake City Salt Lake
City and God damn it Melbourne Florida
King Center September
23rd uh Saturday and then I go right
over to Genesee Theater Waukegan
Illinois on a Sunday at seven o'clock
and I know you guys are dying to come
out on a Sunday we'll see you there uh
then we're at Covina that's next Friday
September 8th two shows right seven nine
three those bad boys almost sold out we
got two shows get your tickets right now
let's go for Covina California the Laugh
Factory Little Theater there there's one
Main Street in Covina so you know where
it's at uh but that's me and Brian
together that is next Friday then
Saturday on the fight campaign for UFC
293 Izzy Strickland with Joe Rogan Trip
Lee counting myself Donovan Spokane
Washington September 21st through the
23rd spoken Comedy Club we're at skank
Fest there doing live find the kids and
stand up uh then I'm in Iowa October
13th through the 14th one show Friday
one show Saturday Niagara Falls is
November 4th through the 5th and I'm in
Chicago in December all right kids
thingsthigboy.com love you guys